well i'm joined now by the school's
minister
nick gibb uh so a big day for students
they finally got none so they've waited
seven weeks after being told their exams
were cancelled
um so how's this going to work
well the teacher will be the will grade
it's teacher assessed grades
uh sh the teacher will look at array of
a range of evidence of the
student's work over the last two years
uh there'll be quality assurance
processes in place
in the school the grades will be signed
off by the head teacher they'll be
submitted to the
exam boards on the 18th of june there'll
be quality assurance
processes in place by the exam boards
they'll have a a sample of
schools they'll go and check those
grades to make sure there is the
evidence that supports them
and there'll be a risk-based uh sampling
as well
and the results will be announced on
august the 10th for a levels and august
the
12th uh for gcses and their and their
equivalents
and they'll be a very robust appeal
process for those students that are not
happy with their grades but we
that given that students will know the
the type of evidence that the
teacher will be using on which to base
their grade
any we hope that any problems will have
been resolved as a school level
a long time before the grades have
submitted
let me read you a quote by doing away
with all moderation it would be
misguided and create deep inequalities
without moderation there would be great
inflation of 12 percentage
points at aced rna casting doubt on the
validity of the grades in the eyes of
employers and
university that was yourself a year ago
saying exactly that that this new system
would lead to great equal inequalities
well we do think that exams are the
fairest system and we were determined to
keep exams but when it became very clear
in january that we were restricting
access to schools to all but the
vulnerable children and
children critical workers given the
disruption that students had faced
over the year the only fair system was
to move away from exam this year
to a teacher assess system and we have
built in very protective measures
we trust the judgment of professionals
who run our schools
but on top of that we have these quality
assurance processes
to make sure that there is a process at
the school level
uh to ensure that the grades are a fair
reflection of the attainment of the
students and then there's that other
quality assurance by the examples
there's also very detailed
guidance that's uh produ will be
produced by the examples and detailed
training
for teachers in how to submit those
exams so there's a whole
raft of measures to make sure that uh
the grades are
are a fair reflection of the work and
the ability of students
but but if you're saying that exams are
the best thing are you basically saying
that this plan is the best of a bad
bunch
i'm saying it's the best we can do other
than exams and exams this year
wouldn't be fair because of the
different levels of disruption that
students have faced across the country
so this is the best system
and we trust the professionalism of
teachers and head teachers
we consulted very widely on the 15th of
january for two weeks
on the basis of these details and and
100 000
responses half of whom were students
uh these this method has achieved
widespread support in the sector
including from the
the heads of some of the big unions and
jeff barton and so on uh
uh has been very supportive of these
measures we've worked very closely
uh with the with the with the schools
with the regulator with the exam boards
um to make sure that we we put together
the best possible method of ensuring
fairness
and to ensure that students can move on
to the next phase of their life we don't
want any student
to suffer long-term damage to their
prospects as a consequence of this
pandemic
but but you're saying it it is
essentially a compromise it's not what
you would like to do
you're putting all your faith in the
hands of the teachers but you didn't
want to do that
last year i wonder what's changed you
know have you suddenly had a revelation
that teachers are quite capable of
monitoring their own pupils
well we put in place as i said these
quality assurance
processes and with very detailed
guidance from examples to make sure
teachers sorry but you're essentially
asking teachers not only to judge their
pupils
but you're asking them to judge their
pupils against other schools and against
the rest of the country how on earth can
can teachers be expected to do that
well teachers are very experienced and
they will know from from
from previous years uh what this
standard that a particular student has
reached given the disruption that they
have faced they will only look at
the work uh where that element of the
curriculum has actually been
taught there are those quality assurance
processes in place at the school level
and they'll be very detailed guidance
from examples about how to judge that
uh how to judge students and how to
create that
range of evidence to support the grades
that have been
it seems like last year you were saying
we can't trust teachers it must be an
exam
and teachers words were totally ignored
when it came to saying that this this
people's perfectly capable getting this
grade and
and you've awarded them a much lower
grade and now it seems you're saying
right teachers are going to have all the
responsibility and quite frankly
if it gets messed up this year we can
blame them
no look you know one learns from uh
what happened in pre last year
and we've worked very closely for many
months
even even when the schools were open and
we were expecting exams to go ahead we
were working on a contingency
in case we had to cancel exams because
of further disruption
uh to children's education we've worked
closely with the examples we've worked
closely with the school sector with
teachers head teachers
every step of the way we've consulted to
make sure
that we can we can divide a system
that's as fair as possible for students
they can move on to the next stage of
their lives
but but you're right of course exams are
the fairest and best system of judging
attainment but we can't have exams this
year because of the pandemic and because
of the
the disruption that many students have
faced up and down the country
it wouldn't be fair to hold exams this
year and we trust professional teachers
are the people that know their students
best
and we do trust their professionalism uh
and we can make sure they're still
saying that but academics are
questioning this system natalie pereira
from the education policy institute says
there's a really high risk
we'll see inconsistencies in the grades
among different pupils and schools
and a significant risk that schools will
take very different approaches to
grading it could result in large numbers
of pupils appealing their grades
or extremely high grade inflation it's
going to lead to chaos in the summer
again isn't it
no um all these risks that uh the epi
are talking about and
are all risk we're all fully aware of of
course this is not
the ideal situation to be in this is a
consequence of the pandemic but it is
the fairest system
given the different levels of disruption
students have faced and of course we are
aware of all those issues
that think tanks and other people that
down over the last the last year
repeatedly
and you're now telling them well look
you've got to go through jump through
these hoops
it's not ideal but it's the best we can
come up with and it's taken us seven
weeks to come up with it
well we were working on this before
christmas
we were able once schools were announced
that schools are not going to be open to
most
students on the 4th of january we were
ready to consult with the details of
this
on the 15th of january so we we've been
very
prepared for being working on this for
many months it is the it is the fairy
system
we want to make sure that students
continue to study so the exam
grades won't be submitted until the 18th
of june that gives more months
of face-to-face teaching as schools are
going back on the 8th of march
we want to do everything we can to help
students
deal with the consequences of this
pandemic the pandemic
has caused all kinds of disruption to
children's education that's what's
driven this
and what we're doing as a government is
trying to make up for that
by a the all the measures we announced
yesterday about
the catch-up the recovery premium and
that builds on all the catch-up funding
the billion pounds that we announced
earlier this year and and the one-to-one
tuition and so on
we want to make sure that no pupil no
student suffers long-term damage to
their prospects as a consequence of this
pandemic
and one of the things we need to do is
to make sure
that they get grades they get their
qualifications this year so they can
move on to
college to university to an
apprenticeship and not have that process
that progress disrupted by this pandemic
and that's what this
system does it's the fairer system that
we could devise working
we've worked very closely with teachers
and with the education sector in
devising it
it's had widespread support when we
consulted including
50 000 students who've responded to the
consultation john cole's
from off call i don't you've heard the
reports this morning that he has
resigned
can you confirm that well he resigned a
little while ago
when one of the committees that he was
on was going to be uh was no longer
needed
look i respect sir john coles very much
indeed he runs in
an effective multi academy trust and he
has his quote
he said the government's desperate
viewers might not though that the
government's desperate not to be accused
of having an algorithm or exams by the
back door
uh focusing on this rather than the
actual goal how are we going to be fair
to young people we risk an outcome in
august much
worse than last year what do you make of
that
so he so he thought that the exam
materials that were
that were making available to teachers
the question banks that they can use as
part of the the range of evidence that
they'll need to supply two examples
about
how they've devised the grade he wanted
that to be
compulsory mandatory we asked that
question in the consultation should
should those materials uh should they be
an option for teachers or should they be
mandatory
and the consultation was very clear that
they should be an option and not
mandatory we didn't want
uh those materials to be regarded as a
mini exam
because you know we've cancelled exams
this year because they were felt to be
unfair
uh given the disruption so we didn't
want to then cancel exams and replace
him with another exam
but that you know john isn't entitled to
his views but the majority of people in
the sector including the heads of the
major unions such as ascal believe that
we have devised
the best possible method given the
circumstances it's
fair uh there are quality assurances and
checks to make sure that those grades do
reflect the work
of the students there'll be a robust
appeal process
and we've got an awesome season series
in case students are not happy they can
take the exams in the autumn
if they wish to do so you mentioned the
summer schools
who who are going to run these because
the teachers as well as now having to
learn a whole new system
and mark all these exam papers have been
teaching some students at school
some online they are quite frankly
knackered
who on earth is going to run these
summer schools
well we want them run from the schools
um and but but there's
the reason why there's funding is to
enable the schools to be able to
employ people to run to take part and
run those summer schools we want a
summer of activities to
who is qualified to teach our youngsters
apart from teachers
well there are a whole raft of people
that will be able to come in
young graduates should teach people who
are training to be teachers retired
teachers
that's a matter for the school to decide
that we are providing
200 million pounds to enable schools to
run those summer schools and that's on
top of all the other measures
uh the billion pounds we've distributed
to schools uh to provide
catch up the the the the national
tutoring program 33 tutoring companies
provide
a few seconds left but how are you going
to ensure that the right people the
right children get this and it's not
just the parents with the sharpest
elbows
that it's actually the children who've
missed out who actually get this help
now we're giving guidance to schools to
focus uh
the these resources to students the most
disadvantaged students
who have suffered the most during the
pandemic to help them to catch up
there's a whole raft of measures as i've
said the national tutoring program the
academic mentors
the premiums that we've given to schools
to help
to fund this we've also appointed sir
kevin collins to look at the
slightly longer term about how we can
ensure that students that need
you know that need to catch up over a
period of months and years
that we have measures in place for those
students as well and we'll be
we'll be listening to what sir kevin has
to say about how we can do that
we are determined that no student will
suffer that
long-term damage to their prospects as a
consequence of this pandemic
and we're backing that determination
with 1.7 billion pounds over this period
to make sure that
that every student will be able to catch
up and today's announcement about how
we're going to make sure every young
person has their qualification
despite the fact we've had the council
exams it's a fair system
and it does mean they'll be able to go
on to the next phase of their of their
career